all right you guys know how I am at this
point if you don't know how I am at this
point I will tell you as of late final
trailers for movies I feel have been
showing too much so when the final
trailer comes out I just skip it I don't
watch it I like being surprised when I
go into the movie so I was like I'm
gonna skip the Planet of the Apes
trailer that was invention out watching
some guilty pleasure TV playing Fire
Emblem awakening on my 3ds and then the
new done and the Planet of the Apes
trailer came on TV it's like it was
seeking me out I was like my god it
found me I don't know how but it found
me run for it Marty obviously the
universe wants to me to talk about that
at this point I do too because it
was pretty cool totally the Planet of
the Apes is one of my top two most
anticipated movies for this summer 2014
season it was excellent Days of Future
past luckily that kicked ass now I'm on
to dawn of the Planet of the Apes I'm
hoping that kicks ass and with every new
trailer it looks like Don of the Planet
of the Apes is absolutely gonna kick ass
we all know that just by now ultimately
the world hinges on the razor's edge of
war between really smart Apes and humans
that humans are eventually gonna lose
what I like about this trailer is it
shows more the relationship between
Caesar and the human in this movie these
two kind of have the same mindset
they're like I want peace between our
people I know all Apes aren't bad
Caesars like I know all humans are not
bad our clans do not unanimously agree
on that concept though and there's a
parallel you know the Gary Oldman with
the humans he's the one who's like no I
kill them all in war and that's the way
we're gonna be dominant but that really
crazy messed up a put the weird
I pushed the helicopter off the bridge
in the last movie he's like the Gary
Oldman character to the Apes he's like
you carry about humans more than Apes
you Caesars trying to be a good leader
and that conflicts happens kind of like
the rock
ed Harris is like I'm not really a dick
and all those little pals are like
listen to soft anything and from there
you realize it's not just on the leaders
shoulders your troops can ruin it for
everybody the human dude even tells Gary
Oldman he's like if you threaten his
family he will retaliate which makes me
think all right when caesar's family
gets wiped out Cesar's gonna retaliate
and I think Cesar's gonna die too and
after that the Apes just enslave mankind
cuz I don't think enslaving mankind's a
Caeser thing to do because Cesar's gonna
die good hoping for peace but like
through the generations of apes they're
gonna be like nas either one of those
through slave mankind it's just as what
the scriptures say I was just one scene
in this trailer that I thought it was
the end of the trailer actually because
it was on TV I didn't know it was a full
trailer I thought it was just a TV spot
these two humans are standing guard with
their guns and then crazy ape starts
doing cartwheels
clapping the Lark do we shoot him I
don't know and I was like is this gonna
end on one of those funny moments I hate
it when trailers do that it a snatches
the gun away and he's like hey man I was
like oh I didn't expand her to why I
didn't expect I shoulda seen it coming
but I was not in deconstruct
entertainment mode I was in watch shitty
TV and play a Fire Emblem mode but such
a clever yet dick moment I liked it my
favorite part of the trailer hands down
but dawn of the Planet of the Apes it
does look awesome
I'm hoping it's awesome there's no real
reason it should be rest assured if
for nothing else know that I have seen
the first two episodes of series 3 of
Sherlock have not seen the third one
I've not played the reason episodes of
the wolf among us and the Walking Dead
Season 2 they're all on my to-do list my
checklist and then steam sales happen
and then Fire Emblem and 40 hours later
in that game what can I say I'm a nerd
with things to do so dawn of the Planet
of the Apes have you seen the new
trailer what did you think about it
every thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more